قال محمود مراد خاني ابن الشقيقه المرشد
الايراني علي خامنائي ان والدته قطعت كل
العلاقات مع شقيقها علي خمن اي منذ عام
2009 واضف اخاني في مقابله مع قناه
العربيه ان اي تواصل يعني ان والدته
وعائلتها يقبلون ممارسات والتصرفات النظام
منوها الى انه ليس هناك تواصل معهم بسبب
حكمهم غير العادي واوضح انها شقيقته
وفريده مراد التي تعتقلها السلطات ثم
تخفيف الحكم عنها الى خمس سنوات لكنه
اضافه انه لا يمكن تاكيد الامر مشيرا الى
ان التظاهرات الجاريه هي دليل على الخلل
في نظام الخامنئي لان هذا النظام يعارض
الديمقراطي ويتطهد حريه النساء منذ 40
عاما واضف خالي انه بعد وفاه خمرئه فان
النظام الايراني لن يصمد وستكون هناك حرب
داخله معتقدا ان مجتبى نجل خامنئي لن يكون
خلفا لوالديه على صعيد اخر اظهر التقارير
استخباراتيه من خارج ايران ان النظام اصبح
على وجهك السقوط بسبب الانتفاضه الشعبيه
وينقصها فقط وجوده زعيما شعبي وتمويل
المنظم اضافه الى دعم من رجال الدين
المعتدلين ليخرج النظام الملالي من الحكم
اعتقد ان علي يمكن ان يعين شخص قبل وفاته
ولكن اذا توفي فان هذا النظام لن يصمد
مرشح لخلافه والده لان النظام يمكن ان
يتلاشى وهمم وستكون هنالك حرب داخليه داخل
النظام وهذا ما يفسر بان بانظام سوف
يتلاشى
الاقارب الاخرين بطبيعه الحال همم هناك
همم الكثير وحتى من طرف خالي وفي عائله
خاله هنالك من يعارض السياسه التي يقوم
بها او التي تسير عليها البلاد خلال سنوات
الماضيه
بطبيعه الحال هم موجودين ولكن همم لا
يمكنهم همم لا يمكن للتظاهر والتعبير عن
حرياتهم كما سبق وقل في البدايه همم وهذا
همم يمكن القولون همم يمكن القول بان همم
الاشخاص الموجودين في العائله لا يعبرون
بطبيعه الحياه على النظام الذي تسير عليه
ايران
من بيروت الكاتب الصحفي حسن فحص ينضم
الينا ومن القاهره محمد مجاهد الزيات
مستشار المركز المصري للفكره والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه اهلا همم بكم ليبدا اولا من
القاهره سيد محمد يعني هذه المره اصبح في
العالم انتقاد النظام بل سقوطه هل هي
خاصره الرخوه ان ياتي هذا الكلام من محمود
مراد هاني القريب لخامنائي ام انه يقفز من
المركب قبل
لا اعتقد انه ال ال كون الناس من الاسره
التابعه القريبه من
يتخذون موقفا على هذا الشكل يعتبر تطور
يعني استراتيجي في المعارضه للنظام لانهم
لا يشتغلون مناصب ذات تاثير لكن ربما كانت
لها معنى فقط ان دائره القريبه منه مستاءه
وتتخذ مواقف لكن المعارضه والحركه
والاحتجاجات القائمه هناك لها معايير اخرى
ولها تقيمات اخرى يعني بعيدا عن اقارب من
ايه هناك ايضا شخصيات اخرى سبقت عائله
خميني ابنه الرئيس السابق والذي كان مهندس
النظام والذي مكن خامنئي من ان يصبح همم
المرشد الاعلى رغم انه لم يحدث على
المستوى ال- ال-
الحوزه المرجعيه العليا وما هو الذي مكنه
منها ومع ذلك ابنته وقفت وتعرضت لضغوط
كبيره من النظام يعني هناك شرخ كبير داخل
النظام نفسه ليس فقط عائله خامنئي ولكن في
داخل النظام ومؤسساته المختلفه متشدده
وغير متشدده طيب الى بيروت والكاتب الصحفي
حسن فحص اليوم اصبح الصوت يعلو بان النظام
سيسقط في حال وفاه همم
هل همم اصبح ذلك الامر طبيعيا هل الحديث
هذا الذي كان سابقا من ان المواقع قد
تتغير ام ان النظام سيسقط وبالتالي لا
بديل لخاميه
لا يعني تحياتي اولا استاذ عادل
والمشاهدين
يعني كل كل الناس ستذهب
تخرج من هذه الحياه لان الموت حق على كل
حال الجميع
من هذا
الحق اذا صح التعبير
لذلك التفكير بمن بعد خمنا ايه
ومستقبل النظام وموقع المرشد الاعلى
بشكل حاجه
كيف سيكون النظام كيف كيف يستمر من سيكون
الخليفه مدى صلاحيات هذا الخليفه هل سيكون
صاحب نفود وصلاحيات واسعه كما كانت لولي
الفقير مطلق همم
ان هذه صلاحيات همم ستتقلص او ستكون شكليه
من الجهه التي ستساهم في ايصال الشخصيه
الشخصيه ال- التاليه بعد خامنا ايه او هو
دورها وكيف هي الصفقه التي
ترتب بين الاطراف
لضمان استمرار نظام انا لا اعتقد ان
النظام سيسقط ولكن همم سيتراجع نفوذه اكيد
سيتخلخل من الداخل اكيد همم لان الشخصيه
المحوريه القابضه
الصارمه التي كانت في البدايات او في
اواسط ولاياته همم في وسط ولايه لانه في
البدايه كان بحاجه الى شراكه على فنجان
للتدعمه وعندما تمكن همم
يعني
المرجح ان المؤسسه العسكريه المتريه الان
وخصوصا الحدث الثوري المتليف من الانخراط
في عمليه الخمع بشكل كبير
وصارم
امام الاحتجاجات التي يشهدها شارع قد هي
هي التي ستمسك
بمفاتيح ومقاليد تعيين الخليفه
والمفاتيح النظام والمستقبل النظام ايضا
طيب المؤسسه العسكريه سيد محمد اليوم هل
ستبغى على هذا النظام الديني ولي الفقيه
وما يتمتع به من ميزات ما بعد الخميني
خامنئي كيف سيؤول الامر هل بالفعل المؤسسه
العسكريه هي التي ستكون مسيطره وبالتالي
لن تعطي تلك صلاحيات لاحد
تستغفر بها يعني هو المؤسسه العسكريه دعنا
نركز على انها الحرس الثوري وازرعه
المختلفه داخل ايران لانه هو المؤسسه
العسكريه هناك يعني السلطتين متوازيين
الجيش والحرس الثوري الحارس الثوري جزء
اساسي من تركيبه النظام ومن المؤسسه التي
يشرف عليها ويسيطر عليها خامينه المؤسسه
العسكريه التي تستطيع ان تنفرد باتخاذ
القرار في التوقيت الحالي لانها ليست طرفا
في داخل النظام او مؤسساته او في دوائر
صنع القرار لكنها قوه ضاغطه ممكن ان تتم
اذا ما تصورنا ان قد رحل القوه هذه القوه
الدقيقه تستطيع ان تذهب على المؤسسات
الموجوده التي معنيه بالاختيار وتكون هناك
مساومات لا تملك القدره اتفق مع الاستاذ
حسن في مقاله وانا النظام ليس مهددا
بالسقوط الان ولكن النظام بعد ما وفي ظل
الطبيعه المحترقه او الازمه التي او
الارباج الذي يواجهه النظام وعمليه البديل
خامنئي اعتقد انه سوف يتجه الى مزيد من
الضعف ومزيد وسيطرته سوف تقل ثم يحدث نوعا
من الانقسام او التباين ما بين المؤسسه
العسكريه والقيادات التي تشغل بناصب في
دوائر صنع القرار ربما نرى تغييرا في
النظام يمكن ان يدفعه الى ترتيب تنازلات
حتى يبقى ولا يسقط بعد ذلك على المدى
الطويل سيد حسن فحص يعني كما يعني فراغ
او رحيله سيترك فراغا كذلك هذه الثوره
التي شملت مختلف الاطياف من الشعب
الايراني تفتقد الى رئيس يقودها هل وجود
شخصيه وغياب هذه الشخصيه حتى الان هي
السبب في عدم تقدم الثوره الى الامام
واسقاط هذا النظام
عادل لانه هذا هذا الفراغ في في قياده
الثوره او سمح
بتظهير الخلافات داخل القوى والاحزاب
المعارضه خاصه الموجوده الخارج لذلك بدات
تتنافس وتتسارع في ما بينها على تبني اا
هذه الحراك او الانتفاض في الداخل في حين
ان الداخل يتصرف بعيدا عن هذه المعارضه
ولا يعيرها اهتماما ويتسرد ضمن الاليات
والامكانيات والمجلات المفتوحه امام والتي
يستطيع او يعتقد انه يستطيع تحقيق انجاز
فيها لذلك الشارع منفصل عن المعارضه في
الخارج التي بدات صراعتها همم تظهر الى
العالم
وبشكل همم بشكل يعني مخيف لجهاز التعبير
وهي حتى الان لن تستطيع ان تتوافق على
رؤيه موحده او خطاب موحد لما بعد بعد
النظام اذا اذا استطاعوا ال ازاحه هذا
النظام ولم يقدموا اي خطاب سياسي متماسك
همم
يحدد دور وموقع ايران في المرحله القادمه
بعد بعد
ازاحه هذا النظام لذلك ما يفتقده الشارع
الايراني الان هو قياده همم واضحه ذات
خطاب واضح ذات استراتيجيه واضحه ذات اهداف
واضحه
لتقطير هذا الشارع ضمن الحراكه واصابه الى
النتائج المرجوه يعني سيد زيات يعني اقسام
الكعكه بنسبه للمعارضه في الخارج قبل سقوط
النظام او الانتصار هل ايضا يؤثر غياب
قاده في الداخل همم كما كان في الثوره
الخضراء على الاقل ليس هناك شخص ربما
تستطيع الاشاره اليها
نعم عدم وجود زعيم في الداخل يستطيع ان
يجمع المعارضه عفوا
ويحركها لكن هناك شيء اخر في ما يتعلق
بالداخل هناك عدم تماثل في مواقف الاطراف
المختلفه او القوه المشاركه في الانتفاضه
او في الاحتجاجات فهناك ما زالت كتله
كبيره داخل هذه داخل الدوله الايرانيه
تؤمن بالدوله المركزيه ولا تتفق مع
المطالبين بحكم ذاته مثلا في محافظات
الحدود كما يطالب الاكراد الكورد على سبيل
المثال هناك كتله كبيره ايضا ما زالت لها
ارتباطات الديولوجيه بالنظام وتؤمن
بالدوله المهدي المنتظر التي تنتظره اذا
من داخل النظام نفسه داخل الاحتجاجات لا
توجد تماثل كامل ولا برنامج واضح يتفق
عليه الجميع اكثر من رفض النظام ورفض
ممارسات النظام ورفض القمر هذا يضعف من
القدرات على اسقاط النظام النقطه التي
ذكرها الاستاذ حسن فيما يتعلق بالانقسام
الكامل بين الداخل والخارج نقطه مهمه
للغايه لانه لو لاحظت التغيير الذي تم في
المنطقه العربيه في 10 سنوات اللي فاتت في
الدول التي شهدت ازمات ارتبطت بتاثير كبير
من الخارج وبيرامج محدده ومموله هذا غير
موجود حتى الان في الحاله الايرانيه طيب
سيد حسن
غياب هذا العنصر الذي يقود الشارع
الايراني ووجود شخصيه كما كانت في الثوره
الخضراء هناك تقارير الاستخباراتيه تقول
ان الثوره ينقصها زعيم وكذلك دعم وتمويل
كل هذه الثلاثه اذا كانت تمويل من الخارج
هل يمكن ان يسقط النظام ام ينعكس ذلك بان
يعطي النظام دفعه من القوه
يعني
غياب التمويل الموجوده صحيح وهذا لا يعود
لعدم
رغبه الدخل في في الحصول على هذا الدعم
ولكن يتعلق برغبه الخارج بعدم التورط في
في الحدث الايراني او في التطورات
الايرانيه لان النظام ما زال يشكل حاجه
دوليه للمواقع القرار الدولي
وهي تستفيد مما يحدث في الداخل الايراني
التي وهذه وهذه الانتفاضه في اضعاف التي
تساهم في اضعاف قبضه النظام لاستغلالها
وفرض شروط على على النظام والحصول منه على
تنازلات على المستوى الاقليم على المستوى
الدولي وعلى ما يتعلق بالبرنامج شكرا
نعم له مبررات همم
بتتعلق بسياسات الدول الخارجيه شكرا جزيلا
لكتب الصحفي حسن من بيروت ومن القاهره
محمد مجاهد الزيات مستشار المركز المصري
للفكر والدراسات الاستراتي الاستراتيجيه
شكرا جزيلا لك وسلامتك راح صوتك قبل خلق